now is that is there is is there like
you said that you there is this there's
the process of once the analysis comes
back from the the metabolomics this
multi-omics analysis with all this mass
spectrometry and liquid chromatography
and stuff like that all this complicated
technological equipment they come back
and all these numbered readouts they're
showing the there they're comparing
right you gave you gave this really good
example you said they're they're
comparing the individual to the
reference population so the reference
population is like thousands and
thousands of people and that and the
average is and then your individual is
either in the red or in the you know in
the of these suicides are in the screen
and yes at that particular age age is
very important because this example that
I give you know most most people don't
know that when you get a value of a
siren hormone they don't know what the
reference range is just their either
your hypothyroid or hyperthyroid and
you're given a range right that's an
illness medicine range what you know
they didn't know that the way that
collected initially was that was the
thyroid hormone levels off for anywhere
anywhere from three years old to ninety
four years old so why should I rely on
that particular data collection right
how am I going to optimize in the
syringe yeah that's good for illness
right but it's not gonna be good for
optimizing health you see so you have to
go to the optimal range when your body
was physiologically supposed to be at
its best yes yes and then now teach us
teach us about this so if there's a you
know let's take me 27 we say we give my
continuous stool and urine samples and
we're getting back this biometric
metabolomic readouts now when when we're
when you're consult like let's say
you're consulting me as the client
right this is again this is way pre this
is health optimization there's no this
is pre any any suboptimal levels now now
let's say that when you get the read out
back and you're analyzing it and you see
that there's maybe the beginnings of a
suboptimal level here here now walk us
through this process how do you know
what supplements for for me or what what
physical interventions for me to go do
what nutrition what's sleep how do you
know these yeah specific things okay
yeah and now you're are you are not in
the realm of lifestyle that's why the
other omics are in there okay so when
when I get it I I treat it exactly as
illness medicine doctors would do it
right it's like okay here's what you're
deficient in but I will move the entire
network not just one right you know that
all of those for example there is
antioxidant regeneration network right
it's vitamin E and there's so and
vitamin C and so on there they're
regenerated they one another
you cannot just race one of those
antioxidants without erasing other so
you have to have a knowledge of how
these things are wired together how the
how the chemistry is network by the body
right to regenerate its own antioxidants
for example and you have to know which
particular which particular amino acids
you know would be for example you are
you you know I see that you you lack
vitamin b6 automatically I should know
that you probably are also suffering
from some form of a mild depression or
just feeling the Blues as a etc because
vitamin b6 is responsible for is a COFA
in the generation of a serotonin a
neurotransmitter so there's a lot of
stuff that fundamental that you should
be knowing you know when you're making
this this protocol so when you come to
me I look at that as a whole right it's
not piecemeal the difference that I do
with illness medicine doctors is that a
okay I felt you know this medicine
doctors here there's here their results
what they do is they try to just give
everything you can't write because you
have to know which one is network to
what and that's your value as a health
of an optimization doctor or
practitioner is that the value you
provide is you know all of that right
now you also know that these things are
affected by nutrition your gut
microbiota for example in this little 72
hours you know when you're eating you
travel to a different country and you're
eating different food your microbiota
will change drastically you know it will
change its the way the way its absorbing
food you know the it's like an ecosystem
in there some of the species will grow
more some will grow less when you're in
Italy eating too much pasta you know
then your your carbohydrate loving
organisms will over grow you know so
these are the kinds of things now that
effect right so when you're like for
example I had a I had a patient a client
in fact the doctor who loved eating
canned food right and even if even if
thin is already banned in in the canning
process you know he's old enough to
accumulate you know before for the
burning of thing right so you could
actually see the pain levels right and
this is why I don't emphasize the the
genome it's because the genome you
cannot see mercury toxicity in the Gina
you cannot see cadmium toxicity
interesting [ __ ] yeah the farther you go
away from from the genome right so this
genome de proteome and the meta below
and transcriptome genome transfer
meet at home yes yes the father get away
from that the the more you get into the
physiological and the environmental
effects yes yes yes and and so now
that's where the exposome comes in right
there yes I'm sure total environmental
exposure to things like you know to
photo toxicity the kinds of light that
you use right you gave you gave these
examples in the in the talk you used you
used as your examples you gave
electromagnetic smog today is hundreds
of times greater than a hundred and
thirty years ago and 5g is coming around
the corner people have electromagnetic
hypersensitivity we stress on the living
cells disturbing immune systems creating
oxidative stress inhibiting tissue
repair so what so that's this egg that's
this extra zone yeah that's the exposome
so the role of my Health Administration
doctors to identify you know what is it
in your exposome that is beneficial or
harmful to your health right because
part of your exposome is a nagging
spouse yeah you know that stress
increases cortisol yes it's it's part of
it and even you know they already showed
that that you know partners who sleep
together where there's one partner is
not whoring they showed that for each
snore you know the cortisol spikes in
the partner that doesn't that's so
interesting you know studies like this
have already been done and they're fun
right but the thing is they do have an
impact on your absolutely around on the
Rupert on the Rupert Sheldrake level we
could talk about it as like a morphic
field in a sense and and we're right
there next to each other creating these
expose ohmic inter place between one
another and there's there's no getting
out yeah yeah I had a pleasure of
actually meeting and speaking with
Rupert Sheldrake in
cover off the coast of Vancouver Cortes
Island he was a guest of one of my
friends and in fact my best friend in DC
and we talked about this morphic field
theory and all that stuff but for me
it's like you know how do we make it
easy for people to remember right but
they know the genes and there's a genome
right and so essentially your exposome
right this is that unit that's refers to
your environment your total exposure to
the environment the genome is through
your jeans and your exposome is to your
environment me I think yes and I can
give also a very brief genomics is what
might happen transcriptomics is what
appears to be happening proteomics is
what makes it happen and metabolomics is
what is happening now or has happened I
like that's what's useful right I'm
treating someone now I so yeah and it's
very fluent by you know I use
metabolomics as as a way to prove it
right now it's at the level of an
abalone because it's what we can prove
right it's not you can show objectively
that here here is what's improved right
it's like I don't rely on anything
subjective but I usually and the case is
like I'm feeling better right
III I'm I'm feeling better or I feel so
much better or some some husband's would
go I'm only here because my wife told me
so I mean then they would come six
months later and they go doctor Ted you
know I thought I was already feeling
better but I didn't know that it was
possible to feel this way so I tell them
my goal actually in getting you here is
to get you addicted to the feeling of
wellness so you know that when you get
off balance you know what it is that
like you're off balance right and you
emphasize now like you know like simple
lifestyle changes right yeah Apple you
be
explain the mitochondria that they are
there bacteria inside your cell you know
we call them or organelles but they're
actually a bacterial origin right there
they have their own DNA you know there
we have a bridge about a hundred
quadrillion of them in your bodies you
know our red blood cells used to have
them but the mitochondria sacrifice
themselves in order for you to have him
all give in right so so and they power
you up right they power you up so you
know that you know way before this
intermittent fasting blah blah blah 11
years ago I was already telling my
clients that you know 12 hours of not
eating anything will allow your
mitochondria to divide and regenerate
right it's just like it's just like
having a kitchen that you give a break
you're cooking non-stop you know and
eating you know we're a shameful species
when we have a permission to eat you
know 24 hours in a day yeah yeah so so
if you just give it a rest of 12 hours
it will start to generate the amount of
people successfully shed 50 pounds or
more off of their body by just fasting
and burning fat or extended I'm and it's
actually really beautiful to train
yourself at young ages to go on a day
fast to day fast at cetera and feel what
it's like to burn fat rather than
glucose right see for me it's like now
you're giving them a scientific basis
for doing you know and besides you know
Alan it's easier for me for example oh
I'm going to change about it no no you
can't what can you promise me that you
can do they can promise me a commitment
to the time that they eat so I said well
you know first try a feeding window of
you know 14 hours and then the next week
reduce it to 12 hours and then 10 hours
you know and then you know yeah exactly
and then have a minimum of like like you
know eight hours you know that's that's
you're feeding window I don't like to
use fasting because fasting sounds
the Prima Torre so yeah use your feeding
window and I usually tell them they can
eat whatever they want but then pretty
soon they feel a lot better when they
see how else can I improve my nutrition
and then you introduce the concept of
your microbiota you know your your gut
microbiota add a way about you know 2
kilos in there so there's a lot of
bacteria that have 2 million genes
2 thousand genes each 2 million genes
which is a hundred times more than we
have human Y so that's that's pretty
impressive yeah the more important fact
is that we now know that the gut the gut
is actually the largest immune system of
the body right when I was in the bone
marrow Wow you know it's a gut because
because it is the bad gut bacteria is
actually teaching what's foreign and not
foreign right so you see this these
reports right these reports where or
analysis where children born by cesarean
section have a lot more allergies and
immune problems because there's improper
activation of their immune system so I
have some OBGYN enterprising OBGYNs who
know about this so they put a gauze on
on the mother's vagina and they do the
they do the cesarean section and they
put a gauze over the face just so that
there would be an inoculation of the
bacteria that was supposed to be there
because what we find right and what do
they find and in analyzing this
children's bacteria they find the skin
bacteria of the people who handle them
first yeah
how messed up is yeah you know it's
supposed to be there right so okay what
if by energetic system mitochondria you
know and then you could teach them about
eating which is microbiota and a gut
immune system yes and we've spoken about
exposome
their lifestyle and then you you tell
them about their sleeping habits right
yes yes yes asleep I cheat because lack
of sleep will actually costs memory
problems huge pathology the main thing
that because of the evolution has
learned this is that the first thing
that it does for any insult in the body
is to get inflamed whatever it is you
will activate your and your NF kappa-b
right that's the that's the pathway that
will that's a simple pathway that it
will that it will do because you know it
has it has the counter pathway to that
to quell it as well right so and we know
that's the first thing that it does
right so any an insult easier your
inflammatory cytokines are coming up
these are molecules you know that Signet
that signified that your body is getting
inflamed even a simple high sensitivity
c-reactive protein test which will show
you that right but your body's inflamed
even if you're feeling good at sat at
cetera you see your HSA or peas right
saying you know that there's stress
there somewhere and then you look back
and say oh my god you know i haven't
been sleeping
really I've been traveling for the past
three days that I've been in different
time zones and you see your HSC RP shoot
up right so these are the and you eat
some proper sleep hygiene and and so on
and you know for you know that you
actually eat 200 calories more the next
day when you lack sleep right because
the body feels that is under a song it
needs more energy and evolutionarily if
the body says you need more energy so
you eat more right it's it's not it's
not like having the munchies but it's
you actually tend to to eat more right
and then and then this is this network's
idea that you're talking it's so deeply
Network right and the cells are talking
to each other is why I say we're looking
at the body as an ecosystem of cells
it's the hollow beyond perspective right
it's a hollow beyond perspective where
whereas in illness medicine we look as
individuals as part of a population
you're right because you're your
surgical technique has to work on the
population or your antibiotic has to
work on a population no we consider you
as the population of organisms yeah yes
your cells are bacterially derived yes
your and your somatic cell is result of
an anaerobic bacterium and your
mitochondria which is anaerobic
bacterium the symbiotic relationship in
the past right so so that's the that's
idea here
it's Helana Klee layered the human and
then inside of us is all the complex but
then also outside of us is the
civilizational influences and and that's
why when you're looking at health it's
impossible to look at you as a person
you have to look at you as a holiday on
you have to look at the human and
everything inside and everything in the
civilization outside all harmoniously
affecting the organism in fact part of
your exposome is the egypt the immediate
absolutely of irises cetera around here
absolutely
so right now you know coronavirus is
part of our exposome yeah yeah yeah so
so normally your own house which will
have its own specific you know
environmental bacteria right it's very
interesting you mentioned earlier
something interesting which is Aubrey de
grâce model and I really love the guy
and the way he thinks right
as a biologist but the model that that
he has actually lends itself really well
to epigenetics which is the last pillar
you know we have seven pillars right off
your mouth optimization as sin and last
billers but genetics it lends itself
really well because he says like here
you are at a younger period right say
you're 21 to 30 your optimal range right
and then at 30 your testosterone begins
to decline that's why I chose 30 right
because this went to the husband because
there you begin to to have to fall apart
right and
what happens then is that you the
chronic diseases begin to appear right
they babies you know metabolic diseases
cognitive decline
you know neurodegenerative diseases they
all begin happening right and then
afterwards it's a period of disease and
then death right and he says what if we
could move ourselves back to before the
time that the chronic diseases appear
that means that the cells would be at a
younger age yeah and of course you know
you already know about the Yamanaka
factors right the Nobel laureate
professor in menachem Japan identified
four factors that you actually make
cells younger and the most recent the
the most recent finding is that they can
now actually make cells younger without
erasing their identity meaning they
don't forget that their muscle cells or
they don't learn ourselves and that's
just you know a recent advance but now
we're taking a look at can we eat it's
like the best metaphor that I use it's
actually quite ugly
it's like accumulating plaque on the
teeth right it's your epigenome and and
then so your gene genetic expression
gets affected like for example if you
smoke and you you have all this other
bad habit a bad habit sir you're you're
you know poorly methylated or whatever
it is toxic like they only have you know
and and you so when you remove that
plaque right then you could move the
cells back to the younger age now can we
do that that the big challenge is that
can we do that now for the entire body
right and so you know David Sinclair you
know is do it now doing that for the I
you know can we reverse the retinal the
macular degeneration that occurs right
so and they found that in in their
laboratory animals they can do so run in
in a closed environment so it's no
longer
it's not no longer a period for us this
is no longer an anti-ageing period this
is our period of age reversal yeah
you have rejuvenation through youthful
homeostatic capacity yeah yes but you
know it takes many years you know look
clinical course didn't catch didn't
catch up with with medicine until now
until you know I I'm one of the people
who's pushing hey these tests are not
available you know we now can have a
better dashboard by which to maintain
hell right yeah I love the - every so
yeah that's why I never used the term
disease prevention that's also illness
medicine crap right they look at
populations you know that's why vaccines
are within therefore he oh interesting
so basically the the dashboard maybe in
the last like hundred years has been
slowly getting more and more variables
popping up on it and and now the idea is
that there's there's like sometimes like
clinical metabolomics can maybe put up a
significant amount of variables that are
really crystal clear and crisp and the
thing is is that your role and a lot of
the time people's roles are to just grab
people and say hello you can add twenty
more variables to your dashboard now
please go do that for all of your
clients as soon as possible stop waiting